Physiologically, stimulants can increase your heart rate, your blood pressure,
and your respiration. They can also decrease your appetite. Now, it's important
to know that this increase in heart rate is really dangerous. Some people have
actually died the very first time they've ever used a major stimulant such as
cocaine or methamphetamine. Long-term consequence of using the major stimulants
such as cocaine and methamphetamine also result in formication. And this is the
feeling of little bugs crawling under the person's skin. As a result, people
often pick and scratch at their skin, which results in open wounds and
increased likelihood for infection. Another consequence is called meth mouth.
And I recommend that you Google that and you can see some unfortunate
descriptions of what that is. Finally, long term use of these major stimulants
in some people, can result in what is called stimuli-induced psychosis. And
here, the individual thinks and behaves somewhat similarly to somebody with
schizophrenia. Some of the other long term consequences of major stimulant use
are hypervigilance, sleep deprivation, anxiety and paranoia. Long-term
methamphetamine use can also dramatically age you. If you Google faces and
meth, you can see just how dramatically meth can affect your appearance. When
people abuse the major stimulants, they often go on what is called a run.
Meaning, they'll continuously take the drug and stay awake for maybe two to
three days at a time. Now, we know that our bodies simply can't stay awake that
long and eventually the person will crash. Due to the crash, they're going to
experience depression, extreme fatigue, and sometimes even suicidal thoughts.
In addition, because the person starts to undergo withdrawal, they usually
begin drug-seeking behavior again. Now, let's go back and take a review of the
major stimulants.